like today I did you know the talks
there their Instagram show and really
was the first day I called my hair
person who doesn't talk because I think
I can fudge makeup that not hair and I
called you up and I said hey Laurie
Laurie captain she's phenomenal talented
oh my gosh she's done a million show us
but very lucky to have her and I called
you up and I said how does it look and
she goes you're right you really can't
do here can you hi Marie how are you
doing it I'm really good how are you
doing
you look very spiffed up oh well it's
Marie Osmond we're not going to be using
the logo at home quarantine look I'm
trying to give you my Marie Osmond I
just want to know do you have roots or
did you paint them you know I'm lucky I
don't I'm oh my gosh you know and I get
it until just the last couple of years
and I always said it and I'm like my mom
I have like a silver streak right there
so let's just jump right into it how are
you handling the lack of Beauty
appointments and things that we as women
typically rely on how are you managing
you just have to laugh about it do you
know I I was talking today we so we do
this fun live chat I'm gonna show you
but we do this sorry anyway we do this
really fun thing on the talk CBS where
we go on Instagram and we do a live chat
go dark go to the Instagram but we were
talking today I was talking to Carrie
Ann how people will try to say that the
ladies at the talk you know we fight
among each other and things like this so
not true there's this awesome text that
we this line that we send each other all
the time and was so sweet Sharon was
like I miss you ladies and everybody
said no I miss you too and so I thought
I'd send them some little means this one
says how we're all gonna look now that
we have to cut our own hair can you see
that
oh wow
that's your spine especially is this
from washing your hands too much and
doing your own nails oh wait
I'll be obviously I'm going so bad and
this one I this backed me up it says it
says four weeks of pandemic Botox
injections beginning to wear off I'll
let you find a secret
you ladies are something the most
beautiful inside and out people I've
ever had the chance to interview you
could never you are we love you and we
love you thank you quality I mean are
you doing anything like are you doing
any at home beauty regimen sore you dine
your hair out of the box is there
anything going on at beauty related sure
that would be a no I don't think I've
ever slept so much I don't remember
sleeping this much so I'm under full
life you don't have my brush 57 years
worked and it's been incredible because
um you know when they when they closed
everything down as CBS because of the
pandemic then I I left there went made
sure my kids were safe that are there
I drove via to Vegas through Arizona and
checked my daughter there Jessica went
to Vegas make sure all the kids were
safe and then because my husband and I
are you know I'm 29 we we decided to
kind of isolate ourselves because you
know he's diabetic and and I have some
immune system issues so we thought it
would just be best to be alone it's the
first time we have been alone since like
forever ever yeah I had I had eight
brothers and he had six siblings and so
it's like I don't ever remember not
having a million people around and it's
really fun we've had the best time
that's what we're trying to do on the
talk is we want a destination where
people can have fun where you know
people are going through some really
hard times right now and to keep people
positive and have space to strengthen
each other I think there's nothing
better than serving each other and and
you know doing these things that you're
doing keeping people informed there's
you know they're at home they want to
know what people are doing and how to
stay happy you know I I just told a
friend of mine she goes how did you do
with all those kids in home school
because we were on the road and I said
what you do is you assign an older child
to a younger child that way they brush
up their math skills on different
subjects and you can even pay them if
you want you know give them some
motivation or whatever but it's also
time for siblings to be together and my
mom did that with us and so there's a
lot of good tips that we can give each
other and share and just you know have
fun well you're at home with your
husband I want to know what is it you
guys are doing to sort of pass the time
during these really long it's so funny
because well the two of us like we're
catching up on some shows that we have
wanted to watch for a while like why
it's so fun right yeah like I'm into
scorpion right now is it scorpions
yes loving it CBS yes I'm loving it and
he had seen it years ago season one so
I'm catching up on season one of them
were just starting season two tonight so
we do a lot of reading a lot of
facetiming with the kids just seeing
what they're doing my daughter I posted
on my Sunday post just gonna might just
go to my social media but she was
panicked because her daughter wasn't
eating anything she sported my little
granddaughter rocket and so she texted
me this photo back and she goes
Nutrisystem saved the day and i know i
endorsed it but my granddaughter loves
their pizzas
I mean loves them and she's there really
quick and she gets to put like extra
tomatoes or cheese or whatever on him
and she has her freezer open and it's
all Nutrisystem pizzas and ice cream
sandwiches she goes we're set she'll eat
you know speaking of Nutrisystem are you
cooking a lot like during your downtime
have you tried new recipes you know one
of the things that I did on a vision
board is like things that I want to do
this year one of them was learning how
to cook diabetic treats for my husband
and suits so I'm doing a lot of research
into that it's a little harder but I
posted also on my social that one of the
things that I found is to take a little
bit of coconut oil and mixed with Lily's
sugar-free chocolates
and then you drizzle it over fresh
raspberries oh my gosh it's too dark for
it
oh I mean it is the best dessert you can
ever have Lily with cream on it if you
want and you can you diet any way you
could just do like no calories and you
don't feel like you're not having the
cookie or a pie or something you know so
good I swear to you now look we were
joking earlier that you're wearing your
I think it's pretty chic your red
sweatshirt looks like some nice
athleisure you're wearing yes I wanted
to know have you been getting dressed
every day or not okay so you've been
living in totally yes and no makeup just
like today I did you know the talks
they're their Instagram show and really
was the first day I called my hair
person who does the talk because I think
I can fudge makeup that not hair and I
called you up and I said hey Lorri Lorri
Fenton she's phenomenal talented oh my
god she's done a million shows but very
lucky to have her and I called her up
and I said how does it look and she goes
you're right you really can't do here
can you and I said no and so she walked
me through the site so this is the
coolest thing she made me pin this all
forward my ponytail and then and then
she said now you pull it over your gray
and then they can't see it so you see
look at you you look technology to do a
hair tutorial I mean I know but like
look how cool that is see it covers it
covers your grave and bangs are and then
that way you just cover it like that and
it's like oh I thank you for sharing
that like tip from an amazing celebrity
hair stylist like hey she did it I
didn't she told me what to do I know but
you actually brought it to life I love
that you know it's fun because you can
there's all kinds of ways you can hide
things and do things and you know that
just that saves time and money and right
now where people can't even go and some
people don't I do know how to color my
hair I just don't have any of the
coloring things here so she's sending me
some I have to tell you that you are my
family I love you all here at the talk
so much you bring up the talk and it's
it's such a delight to watch you with
these women every
for you you're in this routine and now
you guys don't see each other every day
yeah today it was really crazy when I
saw Carrie and I'm like yeah cuz we're
up you really do love each other I've
been checking in on each other how is
everyone else doing you know it's so
sweet
we're all missing each other I think
it's like you said you know I have
worked since I was three years old I
have never not worked one year of my
life and and that's weird you know to
not but at the same time you know I've
been loving the time with my grandkids
face time when my little rocket took the
took the dry ice from Nutrisystem and
was throwing it in the pool and making
witch noises and we will witch getting
so much quality family time yeah it's
been lovely you've been with Sharon or
you know just mostly through the talk we
do that
because I think everybody's kind of just
being private right now I think this is
the time where you kind of were
decompressing but today was so fun to
see her and then of course we've been on
I told you that the memes we send each
other and of course and things like that
yeah you know and I just want to
congratulate you it's been I think
almost a year since you started on the
show full-time right and you just
reflect on that a little bit is this a
job that you see yourself doing for many
many years ahead how much fun have you
had we did do you know it's it's the
thing that's so enjoyable is that you
have your weekends but the top came at
such a beautiful time and I left Vegas
after 11 years and then went right into
the talk and the top came in and watched
the exit there and the entrance there to
that job and it was so cathartic and and
beautiful and I was so grateful to God
because I don't know that I could have
just stopped working do you know and I I
love having that that female energy
because I've never had that this is like
a true sorority where you get this group
of really powerful smart and you know
we're all at this place where you don't
sit at that table and not know who you
are
you better know who you are and and not
be afraid to share things if they can
help people and to be honest and and
it's a really good place at this time in
my life because I can still do my music
but I can sit down and it's it's really
the most wonderful job I've had all you
do is you right before the show you go
we're gonna talk about this what do you
think and you go out and do it it's like
crazy fun Donnie and I have this okay
it's the talk we're gonna tell
everything goal or something where
someone you want to have on or just is
there one thing that you are really
aiming to sink your teeth into in these
next few months with your role on the
top like some sort of like a bucket list
goal I'm gonna go skydiving
you're gonna follow me doing that really
yeah
no no the first of the year we all made
these goals for the year I'm gonna go
skydiving one of them let's go back to
school which I have started and I think
I'm gonna go into religious studies
I love all religions I just think
they're so connected and you know I
think we need to stop isolating
ourselves and it's like this like our
country you know we're getting we're so
angry and we isolate ourselves well if
you don't believe what I believe you
know what we can all just appreciate
what we all believe and share a little
love out there I cannot wait to see your
expression on your face when we take the
cameras with you skydiving oh hey that's
what my dude okay right now we need a
lot of joy and a show that brings me a
lot of joy other than the talk is the
masked singer and your brother Donnie on
the mask singer and a lot of fans have
expressed an interest in you doing it I
want to know no thank you
really right but you know is interesting
I talked to to Kelly Osbourne and Donnie
too and he said you know it was really
interesting because they both kind of
have these a little bit of panic you
know and things like that and you have
to sit in a room isolate it all by
yourselves and then you get in a suit
and then you sing and everybody's trying
to guess
and then you take your you take your
head off and you're like okay device and
your I don't want to go through this
house and go hello goodbye you'd rather
just dazzle us as yourself asthma is
kind of not interested in that
hey Dulli lady said it was so it was
really tough and I did Dancing with the
Stars prior to him and I told him I said
I told him everything to do and not do
but I think I mean I loved it I think
the show is great I haven't really
watched that much I watched him he was
on a few chunks because he was going
back and forth from Vegas to that but
you know hands off to people to do it I
think anybody who wants to for me though
I don't think I want to be isolated if
my kids needed me or you know somebody I
just don't know that I would do that you
know
[Music]